The Red Woman Melisandre has uttered many
memorable lines throughout Game of Thrones
history.
"Death is coming for everyone and everything.
A darkness that will swallow the dawn."
Fans can always count on the mystical priestess
to deliver powerful truths while propagating
her faith in the Lord of Light and changing
the lives of many - for better and for worse.
One such Westerosi whom Melisandre has crossed
paths with is Arya Stark, and on the latest
episode of Game of Thrones, the two women
had a conversation that has ignited a fascinating
theory about where the series will go from
here.
Just before Arya takes a flying leap at the
Night King and kills him with her Valyrian
steel dagger, and just after Beric bravely
sacrifices his life to save Arya's as she's
overwhelmed by wights in the corridors of
Winterfell, she meets with Melisandre for
a mid-battle chat.
This isn't the first time Melisandre and Arya
have spoken: the first encounter they had
was on the third season of Thrones, when Melisandre
prophesied Arya's future.
“Brown eyes, blue eyes, green eyes.
Eyes you'll shut forever.
We will meet again."
Arya did indeed shut many eyes forever before
finally slaughtering the Night King, a move
which also killed his entire army.
When she and Melisandre met again, Arya confirmed
that the priestess can actually see the future.
"You said I'd shut many eyes forever.
You were right about that too."
"Brown eyes.
Green eyes.
And blue eyes."
Off Arya went to kill the blue-eyed Night
King, thus sealing shut her second set of
eyes.
But what about the third eye color Melisandre
mentioned?
Many fans believe that those green eyes belong
to none other than Cersei Lannister and that
Arya will murder the Mad Queen when she and
the survivors of the Battle of Winterfell
arrive in King's Landing on the next episode
of Game of Thrones.
Cersei's eyes are definitely green, described
by author George R.R. Martin as a perfect
match to the emeralds of a tiara she once
wore.
Actress Lena Headey, too, has green eyes.
However, astute fans will recall that Arya
has already killed someone with green eyes:
Littlefinger.
His peepers are said to be gray-green and
cat-like in Martin's A Song of Ice and Fire
book series, though actor Aiden Gillen's eyes
are blue in real life.
If Arya does have more green eyes to close,
will she actually kill the emerald-eyed Cersei?
The Mad Queen is one of a few names left on
Arya's hit list, standing with the Hound and
the Mountain, so there's not exactly a lack
of desire to murder her on Arya's part.
There's also a strong chance that Arya might
murder Jaime Lannister, Cersei's twin who
shares her eye color, then implement the techniques
she learned at the House of Black and White
in Braavos to disguise herself as Jaime and
kill Cersei.
Such an act would connect to another major
Game of Thrones prophecy: the one Cersei received
in her youth.
In a Season 5 flashback, fortune teller Maggy
the Frog told Cersei that she would marry
a king, he would father 20 children and she
would give birth to three, and her children
would each taste power before dying while
she was still alive.
In Martin's novels, the conversation continues,
and Maggy tells Cersei that she will eventually
be overcome with grief and pain.
At that time, she will be murdered by a Valonqar
- the word for "little brother" in High Valyrian.
Cersei's other sibling Tyrion could be the
little brother who murders her, especially
given that he's bent the knee to Daenerys.
However, "valonqar" means little brother and
not littlest, meaning that Jaime, who was
born minutes after Cersei, could also be the
one to kill her, or at least someone who looks
just like him.
Arya stealing Jaime's face to do the deed
would be a surprise twist for viewers, and
might even link up to Maggy's mention that
a "younger and more beautiful" queen will
cast Cersei down and take all that she holds
dear.
Perhaps Daenerys will be the one to ask Arya
to murder Jaime as revenge for the Lannister
man slaying her father during Robert's Rebellion.
Then, Arya might snatch Jaime's mug, fulfill
Maggy's prophecy by murdering Cersei as Jaime,
and clear the Iron Throne for Daenerys to
take.
Since few predicted that Arya would even kill
the Night King on the latest episode, there
really is no saying how sound these theories
are or anticipating what exactly will happen
next.
Hopefully, the next episode of Game of Thrones
will clear up any lingering questions about
Arya and Melisandre's conversation and reveal
whether Cersei will live to see another day.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about Game of
Thrones are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.